foreign sector good morning now um i
know it's not over until it's over
but what can we expect to hear and what
do you hope to hear from the prime
minister
uh this afternoon well look the we've
seen the worst crisis probably since the
second world war
and i think if we're all honest a sense
countries have perhaps been going their
own way
and what this g7 summit under the uk
presidency and the prime minister's
chairmanship has delivered is a a global
gear shift in international
collaboration now you're going to get
the full communique at two o'clock
just in time for the football but let me
just give you a sense of what's going to
be in there
we led the way with our offer 100
million vaccines from our surplus
domestic supply
we now believe that we've got a
commitment for a billion doses to go to
vaccinating the world by the
middle of next year the current
trajectory had us on the end of 2024
so that is a game changer in dealing
with the pandemic and getting the world
back to normal
on climate change g7 leaders have
previously committed to net zero by
uh 2050. what we've got is a series of
commitments
to harvard missions by 2030 and a whole
range of uh commitments
to not just then coal but then the
finance of coal so i think you're going
to see
that global gear shift and that's what
global britain's all about
we hear the gear shift but honestly uh
a lot of this probably could have been
done after 18 months
where we've done things by zoom actually
did we need all the ballyhoo
to get that done i think it was settled
before they all got here
no it hasn't been i can tell you from my
own personal experience with this is the
first net zero g7 summit by the way
so we're talking the talk not just uh
walking the walk not just talking the
talk but actually you do need to get
leaders
around the table if you want to stop
this sort of fragmentation
if you want to see global cooperation if
you want to deliver that global
gear shift in international cooperation
which the prime minister
has been at the vanguard of you've got
to get the leaders together let's
talk about the big issue that's for
today and that is the
billion vaccine doses um
the head of the who and also the common
secretary commonwealth secretary
and others are saying it's really not
enough the number they're looking for is
11 billion
and they want them sooner isn't this
just
feeling a bit like a gesture rather than
a real way of solving the problem of the
developing world
well of course uh the the extra doses
that have been achieved are a billion
but that's two billion in total
uh that the that has been uh uh
committed to by the g7
and we've been leading the way um but
look the let me let me big big gap
between one billion
and eleven so let me show you let me
just demonstrate for your viewers what
that means
if we carried on the current trajectory
we wouldn't have the world vaccinated
till the end of 2024
and what we've now shifted that if we
can deliver on that which i'm confident
we will today
is that by the middle of next year the
world will be vaccinated that's 18
months difference that is a massive step
change
of course we want to go further and
faster and of course it's worth
remembering that we pioneered 90 million
pounds of taxpayers money
into the astrazeneca vaccine 95
of the kovacs vaccines going to the
poorest countries of the world and now
because of the az
vaccine and because of that investment
the problem is though foreign secretary
is speed it's speed uh
next year isn't going to be fast enough
we're seeing in our own country
we're having to turn on the sixpence
because this thing develops so fast
and come back to what the head of the
who is saying
we need more vaccines faster
and actually giving a billion fine but
actually it won't
stop this thing getting out of control
shouldn't we
really be thinking about putting more
resources in now
and getting more vaccines across to
people now
that's what we're doing i mean the extra
billion comes in now
it expedites more than the billion well
of course it's easy to say at the end of
a summit when everyone said it was
impossible
and we've shifted the dial by 18 months
in terms of world vaccination
say it's not enough i think actually
people understand that is a massive
step change and it's one where the uk
has led the way and of course
we've uh you know we've got our own
domestic uh roll out we're we're doing
very well but we've got enough
certainty of supply that we could give a
hundred million that has
a vaccine of excess vaccines that has
helped galvanize and the prime minister
has been able to say look we're leading
by example come on join the effort but
just very quick it is a matter of
priorities isn't it
you saying the integrated review
document you've published very proud of
that you're outspending the nato target
we're
undershooting our oc's development
target
the point is are you getting the
priorities right we're spending more
money
on guns perhaps we ought to be spending
more resources in time
and getting vaccines into people's arms
well look i don't think it's a zero-sum
game
a lot of the work we do for example i've
seen in east africa training
uh countries like the the peacekeepers
to put out
uh explosives uh improvised explosive
devices that
al-shabab elect are also about
development i don't think there's a zero
sound game
in terms of development i mean actually
the third thing i was going to point to
is what we're doing on girls education
the prime minister has been driving 40
million more girls
into 12 years education we have put the
biggest contribution
into the global partnership for
education 430 million i think you'll see
in the communique
billions extra coming from other
countries to hit that target i want to
come back to that but
let me just uh ask you about what the
prime minister of
ireland has been saying this this
morning told sky news that a practical
arrangement on northern ireland
could be reached yet the prime minister
yesterday said
that he was ready to invoke article 16
of northern ireland protocol essentially
putting a stop and that's it's pretty
belligerent isn't it when
the irish are saying let's make a deal
you're the chief diplomat for the
government are you going to be telling
the prime minister when he speaks this
afternoon
call it and the prime minister has been
very calm but also firm about this
what we see article 16 is a bit previous
let me answer the
the challenge that you rightly make
we've seen a very lopsided approach to
the northern ireland protocol which is
supposed to protect
all communities in northern ireland not
just the eu equities but also on
article 6 you'll be familiar with it the
free flow of trade and goods between
northern ireland and great britain that
hasn't happened fully
one in five of all of the eu checks and
controls to protect its border from
central and eastern europe through
around to the south of the
of the continent up to north mountain
one in five takes place
in orlando that cannot be right so what
we want is a more proportionate flexible
approach if mayhem martin is willing to
press the commission on that
fantastic we want tensions eased
we want a flexible pragmatic approach
what we cannot have is both the northern
ireland
protocol being applied in a very
lopsided way or the good friday
agreement being undermined as a result
of it
you're talking about the way it's
applied but let's let's just get back to
basics
you sign the thing then the eu is
sticking to the letter of the deal
they're not no now you're saying
now you're saying let's let's be a bit
more practical let's be a bit
bit more flexible why did you sign the
deal in the first place that's an
inaccurate this was coming
trevor that was that's an inaccurate
characterization of course
the northern ireland protocol is a
package it's got bits to protect the eu
equities
it's got bits to protect the free flow
of goods between great britain northern
ireland for example
trade facilitation under article six the
problem is
the commissioner insisting on a very
lopsided purist approach
if we have a sensible pragmatic flexible
approach and we put
loads of proposals to the other side if
they're now in a position to come back
and show the
flexibility because you know when this
happens in northern ireland it has
real life effects on the communities and
the businesses there okay let me stop
you there
your colleague lord frost says it's
legalistic by which he means
it's what's down there in the paper and
you're saying
it's purist but it is the deal
you want it to operate in a different
way for
what it says on the paper and that might
be perfectly reasonable but you've got
to accept the eu
are not in the wrong in saying this is
what we agreed
why don't you stick to it trevor your
assumption and premise i'm afraid is
flawed i've given you one example
article six
which talks about free-flowing trade
between uh measures to facilitate the
free flow of trade between britain and
northern ireland there's many others
and the the truth is the northern
ireland protocol was a compromise what
we need is both the letter and the
spirit to be respected
we've come up with proposals we've given
them to the commission what we cannot
have is the continuing
disruption of trade and effectively
trying to change the status of northern
ireland
contrary to the wishes or the consent of
the people which is not just contrary to
the northern ireland protocol
but also the belfast agreement let's
stick with the diplomacy
issue um is it right
that president macron said
that northern ireland was not part of
the united kingdom and
the he was rebuked by the prime minister
well i what i don't do
as a matter of diplomatic
professionalism come out and spill the
beans what i can tell you is no one
should be surprised by
these reports and it's not just one
figure we have seriously seen
senior eu figures talk about northern
ireland as if it was somehow different
country from the uk
that is not only offensive it has real
world effects on the communities north
london
creates great concern great
consternation but also trevor could you
imagine if we talked about catalonia
the flemish part of belgium one of the
lander in germany
northern italy corsica in france as
different countries
we need a bit of respect here and also
frankly an appreciation
of the situation for all communities in
northern ireland
yeah but uh let's come back again to the
same point you signed the deal
and why would they not think that way
well the deal has
countless provisions protecting all
sorts of equities
you're shifting the gold posts again
secretary let me answer let me answer
because i i accept the challenge that
you're putting down
but in a deal which has a package
reflecting provisions that
protect eu equities but also protect uh
the integrity of the uk
both sides of that deal must be
implemented our challenge back to the eu
is you're doing this in a lopsided way
if they want to now come to the table
with flexibility goodwill and pragmatism
we would love to see this issue
resettled
because for us the key issue i missed
some of the ignorant comments that have
been made about northern ireland what
else really
matters is the businesses from all
communities the livelihoods the
the the the sense of consternation
anxiety
in communities on all sides in northern
ireland we need to give them that
reassurance this is all about leadership
um
does it show great leadership for uh the
world's
leaders to gather at a barbie
where there are more than 30 people more
than a limit that ordinary people will
be able to have at their weddings
and where the only people wearing masks
were
the staff now i can understand that
there will be all sorts of
precautions and so on but it's not a
good look is it
look it's outside you can see it's very
well ventilated on the
on the beach we've done we've taken i
have a wedding i can only have 30 right
inside our outside is trevor both in
terms of
the checks that have been done the daily
checks for covid
um the the precautions the slimline
delegations
we have taken every measure possible to
make sure this is not just
uh kobit secure but able to take place
and i think we've gone
well beyond and above in terms of make
sure making sure
that this is covered secure so um it's
pretty good signal that if you're having
a wedding and you can have it outside
you can probably have more than 30
people and uh not wear a mask
well the g7 is not 30 people but there's
there were more than 30 people at the
barbecue the pictures are all out there
there was social distancing that that
they were not
social distancing well you know trevor
we we look
very carefully i mean honestly i i'm not
blaming you for this foreign secretary
all i'm saying is
it's out there and actually
maybe somebody tripped up maybe somebody
made a mistake but
it's out there and people will be
reasonably saying
you're not allowing me to gather with my
friends and family at a wedding or a
funeral
but look at what you guys are doing in
fairness uh there have always been
different
uh principles for social entertainment
or weddings than for government business
now you may make uh light of barbecues
for the powerful
no no no those rules have been the same
all along okay but i think people will
understand i think your viewers will
understand the serious business
of bringing leaders together to bring
back the economy stronger
greener deal with the pandemic shift the
point at which
the whole world is vaccinated from 2024
to the middle of
next year that's a serious business that
they're engaged in uh amidst all of the
uh the leisure activities on the beach
straightforward question
21st of june will restrictions be lifted
or not
well as you know the prime minister will
set out the proposition tomorrow
we're in a race against if you like to
roll out the second dose of the vaccine
against the variance we need to assess
the data very carefully we've done a
great job with this vaccine rollout but
as the
pm said we want to proceed irreversibly
and that means we need to do it
carefully and cautiously
so it feels like we're in a realm where
we could be back i can't account for the
value i feel this morning but i can tell
you that you'll get the full answers
tomorrow
let's talk about the harry dunn case
have you given up on the possibility of
ann sakulas the american
diplomat or diplomat's wife uh returning
to united kingdom
to face justice there's a heartbreaking
case i've been lazing of course with the
family
and what we've said is that we would ask
the new administration its position on
the extradition request
their position hasn't changed but we've
also wanted to be clear and the
president
uh the prime minister discussed it with
the president uh here at canberra's bay
that there ought to be no obstacles if
you like politically
to the lawyers the cps talking to anser
coolest his lawyers there's no
no objection to them having a
conversation to see whether a virtual
trial
could be done which can ensure
accountability and some measure of
solace for the family
and that's uh and that's what has been
agreed did you raise the question of
extradition with president biden
the prime minister did yes he asked
president biden
whether it would be possible to
extradite this individual
from the united states to britain so
both myself with
secretary of state lincoln but also the
pm with the president and of course at
official level
have tested very carefully whether the
fundamental position
on the extradition request has changed
it hasn't we've pressed this
but equally if that is not possible and
we've made our
clear our position clear there's been a
denial of justice we want to see
the obstacles removed that at least uh
the lawyers on all side
can discuss whether it's possible to
have a virtual trial and i think that's
a step forward
alongside the civil suit that i've been
supporting that the family have been
taking
in america geopolitics now um
the american president is going to meet
mr putin later on this week
henry kissinger says in the new book of
essays by gordon brown
that we're heading for a new cold war
between liberal democracies like ours
and authoritarians russia and china
and you actually in your integrated
review say that
russia will remain the most acute direct
threat to the united kingdom
do you agree with kissinger new cold war
no i don't quite like the analogy
because it looks
back and we had a bipolar world in those
days effectively ussr in the u.s
with its allies and we have a much more
multi-polar world today but what i do
see is the threat that russia poses
on the border with ukraine with the
buildup of troops the
the use of a chemical weapon on alexei
navalny hot on the heels of what we saw
in salisbury
its use of cyber attacks in a way which
is totally different from the cold war
are we seeing cyber not just from russia
and not just from the russian state used
to attack schools
hospitals we've got to adapt to the new
threats that we face
we will do so by being absolutely clear
with russia and other hostile
states that we will hold them to account
and apply a cost
for their malign behavior equally we
would like to get the relationship onto
a better footing the door of
of uh diplomacy is always a jar always
open for better behaviour
i noticed in that answer you didn't
mention china now
um it's because you asked me about
russia i know i said that you picked out
russia as
a specific threat but the americans
clearly are more worried about
china which is uh but the interest but
let's integrated review is littered with
how we will deal with china
well let's talk about china um did you
discuss
uh as i think the head of the world
health organization has suggested
have you discussed the wuhan uh leak
or alleged leak this weekend uh i
haven't personally but of course it's
created uh part of the backdrop and
officials have been comparing notes on
this
if you're asking me whether we think on
the balance of probabilities if you like
that it originated in a lab
our best information for now is that it
didn't but we don't
have all the answers that's why
internationally we wanted the review to
be able to go in
to china to get all the answers to have
all the cooperation so we have the full
picture
rather than these possible potential
plausible options
but on balance we do not believe that it
came from a laboratory we think it's
much more likely to have been to have
jumped if you like from
animals to humans can i come back to
very briefly at the end
to an issue that looked like was going
to be a big question last week which is
the foreign aid
budget which um you have
you avoided let's put it that way but
it's going to come back
here is the issue that andrew mitchell
and other rebel
tory mps are racing is it
right is it the right priority for the
government to be putting
yet more money into defence and so on
but taking effectively four billion
out of what was anticipated in foreign
aid doesn't that mean
you can send more troops to mali but you
will be withdrawing money from the girls
education you talked about
from water clean water programs and so
on
actually doesn't that really
create a problem for us we're not
exercising the soft power we should
because we're putting the money in the
wrong place well look i don't accept the
binary
uh siloing of what we do for security of
countries from there
the soft power and the age we put in you
gave the example of mali we put in
300 extra uk troops precisely to
stabilize
not for any particular raw direct
national security threat to the uk but
to stabilize that
clinics in that region now you then ask
me about girls education actually at
this um
summit we've announced 430 million
pounds for the global partnership for
education that is the biggest donation
we've ever made now of course because of
the impact of the pandemic on the public
finances we've had a
we've had to re-prioritize i think
people at home would think it was odd if
we were reprioritizing other budgets but
we didn't even look at the
international budgets but we're putting
in 10 billion
pounds in aid this year we're leading by
example the third biggest g7
uh global contributor and if you look at
this communicate out at two o'clock
you'll see the good that global britain
can do